hi checking in with you
i hope you're doing well
it's a difficult time for everyone
i understand some of you will be feeling
anxious or worried it's totally natural
it's important that we all play our part
and ensure that we follow the rules to
ensure that this lockdown is as short as
possible
over this time council staff are working
remotely to make sure that we continue
to support our community
we're here to help if needed please call
us on oh 800 965
or email
office at wmk dot gavt
dot nz
if there's anything we can do to support
you
we will keep our council website updated
updated so head to
waimakariri.govt.nz for updates or check
in on our council facebook page
while we can't see people outside our
bubble
we can call or message our neighbours
friends and family and keep in touch and
that's important over this time
we've got through this before and we
will do so again
take care